種族保存が目的っていう風に校長がおっしゃってたのに対して自分はそんなことない。自分がこう幸せになるために生きてるっていうコメントがいくつかあったんですけど、これについてどう思いますか?
うん。わがまま。自分さえよけえという。大体お前がおるのは
億年の間種族保存に勤めてきたから今のお前がおるんやないか。だけど自分だったらそいつはもうその責任は勘弁してもらおうと。
俺は俺のためだけに生きるよというそう
いう言い方やからな。卑怯もやることを
ちゃんとやってからあれせ生物の宿命なん
だ。種族保存っていうのはそのために
生き取るんだからまずそれを果たせよ。
それから好きなことやりゃええんだ。
大体自分の幸せのためつてもどうやったら
幸せになるか知ってな。種族保存が生きる
目的だともうすでにそれを終えてる人とか
あとはその不妊とか体の都合で妊娠する
ことができない。
方とかはどのように生きるのが良いとお考えですか?
もうその人はしょうがないじゃん。もうあの免除されるよ。自分が悪いわけないからな。おそらく。だけどあれはいかんよね。
LGBTQ
は同じように認めるわけにかんやないか。
はね。種族保存に適さないわけやもん。とは小さくなっとっくれんかな。
俺があんなにも無心をやってある人俺たちの権利はんであれはいかんよ。
校長の意見としてはLGBTQも別に1
人前として認めるとかではないんだけど自分たちで生きてる分には全然オッケーって感じなんです。
もうしょうがないやないかそれしか生きれんのやからね。保存放棄しとるわけやろ。だけどるな。だから偉いなんてことはないんやで。ある程度小さくなっとるやん。
みんなが責任を果たしとる時にそれは
果たさんわけ。堂々に扱えるなんてこう
叫ぶんじゃない。名古屋最建計画今やっ
とるけど完全な復元にしようとしとるわけ
よ。木造にしてね、中外全部逐上当じる
そのままのものを作ろうとしとるんよ。そ
したらね障害者団体から文句がついて
エレベーターつけろって言うんや。
エレベーターなんてその当時なかったんだ
から復元じゃなくなっちゃうやん。だけど
彼らの言分は上まで階段で上がれんという
わけよ。障害者やからね。だから
エレベーターをつけるのは当然やないかと
。俺らの権利だと言い出すわけ。それない
で逆差別やない。他の人に迷惑かけるやろ
。その他大勢にっていうのはそういう方向
にあのマスコミのバカどを持っていくから
いかにもそれが正論であるかのことね。
これがリメラルだ。
長の共通した考えとして、あの、弱い人が偉いんじゃなくて、強い人が正しいっていうのが結構根底にあると思うんですけど、
これは何が背景の考えなんですか?
強いの意味やね。強いの意味は授況、まだ授況やってないけど授業読むとよう書いてあるよ。強いとは何なんやろうと。結局がその答えを出しとるね。然の木を養う。権能を完璧にするということや。
質も量もこれが最強なんよ。本能の強さに
よって人間の強さが決まる。理性やない。
理性は強さなことばっかり口だけ番長が
できてくるんやけどね。だから本能の
トレーニングというのをしっかりやらない
か
。外国の精神論はまず間違えだ。日本の
精神論ヤ和魂。これは正しいんだ。だから
しっかり魂を小さい頃から身につけさして
で生活してみ昔の日本が取り戻せるよ。
悪いやつはいなくなる。どんどんいなく
なるから。あれの話したから江戸時代の
末キにシュリーマンが日本にやってきた。
で、シュリーマンがびっくりしたのはこれ
はまるで天国だっていう意味や。日本と
いう国はエルドラドやユートピア日本は
そうなんだと。なぜかと言うと、これほど
幸福な顔をした国民は世界中にいない。
ヨーロッパから来たああいう文化人やね。
鎖国が溶けともみんな日本にわーって来た
んや。全員が言っとるんやと。おかしい
やろ。明治維新あれは革命じゃないという
ことや。国民は幸せ一杯なんやもんて。
革命を起こすはずないよね。あれは
クーデタークーデターだからその
クーデターを正当化するために江戸時代を
悪く言った。とんとない時代やったんやぞ
と。だけど実際はそんなことなかった。逆
やったんやね。そうするとね、こういう
ことが言えるんや。政治をヤ和魂、ヤ和魂
をさらに発展させたのが武士。武子で政治
を行ったら国民が幸せになったんだと政治
の目的は国民を幸せにすることやろ。武導
が正しかったから国民が幸せになった。
武蔵というのは大和魂を道にしたもんだ。
ヤ和魂が正しかった。科学的だったから
国民が幸せになるという結果が出たんだね
。そいつを否定したわけやろ。明治で1回
、戦後で1回で戦後は強烈よね。マスコミ
朝日を中心にして山反対反対をもずっと
言い続けて愛国心は悪いことや。国旗も
あげるな、国家も歌わない。そうやって
協育したんやで。ちゃんとした人間が
できるわけないじゃん。全部マスコミの
せいだ。我々もそうなんやで。何
度も言うように俺は理系だから絶対におかしいと思っとったや。小学校の頃からやぜ。リベラルはおかしいんやと思っとったん。特に国旗国家を否定したっていうとこから国旗あげたかったん国家も歌いたかったんそれなのに歌うことはならんと言われた。ま、おかしいと思うわね。
何を持って校長は1人前子供から1
人前になったっていう風に考えるんですか?
独立したら。だから人生の目的に会うようになったらええんだ。
人生の目的は種族保存。これが第1な
んだから他のことはほったらかしといてもまず種族保存ができるようにさないかん。就職をして嫁さんもらって子供を作って子供を
人前に育てる。これでも本人の責任を果たしたんだ。それができるようにするのが
1人前やないか。子供と1
人前の境い目みたいなところで何を持って大人というか尊重する対象とするかみたいな何か
LINEありますか?1
人前になる時分かるんよ。反抗機だから第
一次反抗機3歳ぐらいやね。あれは母親に
対する反抗だ。母親があんまり可愛いもん
で話さんやろ。話さんと外へ行けんやない
か。外へ行ったら他の大きい子供に揉まれ
て成長していくんだ。強くなっていく。
母親が邪魔なんだ。だから母親に反抗する
の。これが第1次反抗機から第2次反抗機
。ちょうど反抗機だからあいつはしょうが
ないやというような頃だ。それは家庭から
の家庭に対する反抗なんや。みんなに
嫌がられて外へ行こうとしとる。1人前に
なったからね。もう俺は1人前だからお前
らの世話になら外行って自分の人生を歩む
。これが反抗機だ。今ほら単なるわがまで
反抗機じゃないやつが多いじゃん。要出て
いかんじゃん。わがまと反抗機の違い
はどうやって判断してるんですか?
わがま止めれんのや自分で。反抗機は自分
が嫌がられようとしとるんだ。自分が
嫌がってくれれば外へ追い出されるじゃ
ないか。それを狙っとんのが反抗よ。これ
がないやつはダメな。だから少なくとも表
だって反抗はしなくても心の中で反抗する
。それだけはできんといかんよ。もういら
んせはやなという。俺は俺でやってくよっ
て。今外に出てくのが怖いとかうちにおっ
たら飯が食えるからとかおやん。これは
反抗機がないんだよね。
反抗機がないのは何が原因なんですか?1
輪になってないから。1
輪なってない。どうしてかと言うと進歩してないね。どうしてかと言うと区がなかったんや。不快感が悪くさん自分で発生してればそれで持って行動して強くなる。人間性が高くなるていうのと強くなるっていうのは同じことや。弱いやつはダメ。それを今強いやつはダメにしようとするやろ。ベラルというのはだからいいかんや。
あと抑えちまって強くならんといかんのだ
。どうしてもね。
[音楽]